THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪ ♪
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING, I'M
BRET BAIER.
THIS WAS NOT THE KIND OF HOLIDAY
GREETING PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
EXPECTING FROM THE HIGHEST
RANKING JUDGE IN THE COUNTRY.
SUPREME COURT CHIEF JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS IS DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTING THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT ON THE SUBJECT OF
JUDICIAL BIAS.
IT DID NOT TAKE LONG FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO RETURN FIRE.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE IS
OUTSIDE THE MAR-A-LAGO COMPOUND
IN WEST PALM BEACH TONIGHT WHERE
REPORTERS SPENT THE DAY WATCHING
THE PRESIDENT'S TWITTER FEED, A
FEAT ACTIVE AGAIN JUST MINUTES
AGO.
GOOD EVENING.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ON THE MONEY,
GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
FRANKLY, THIS WAS A RARE REBUKE
FROM THE CHIEF JUSTICE BUT I
THINK IT UNDERSCORES A FAIRLY
COMMON FRUSTRATION AMONG JURISTS
THAT POLITICS HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
PLACE IN THE COURT OF LAW.
>> THE NINTH CIRCUIT IS REALLY
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> WHAT BEGAN AS A PRESIDENT'S
SHARP CRITIQUE OF THE
NINTH CIRCUIT YESTERDAY, TODAY
CAME TO THE PILLARS OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
BUT CHIEF JUSTICE CHIEF JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS CHIDING THE
PRESIDENT FOR INJECTING POLITICS
INTO THE COURT.
WE DO NOT HAVE OBAMA JUDGES OR A
TRUMP JUDGES, HE WROTE, BUSH
JUDGES OR CLINTON JUDGES.
WHAT WE HAVE IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
GROUP OF DEDICATED JUDGES DOING
THEIR LEVEL BEST TO DO EQUAL
RIGHT TO THOSE APPEARING BEFORE
THEM.
THAT INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL BE
THANKFUL FOR.
THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED ON
TWITTER, SORRY CHIEF JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS, BUT YOU DO INDEED
HAVE OBAMA JUDGES, AND THEY HAVE
A MUCH DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW
THAN THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CHARGED
WITH THE SAFETY OF OUR COUNTRY.
ROBERTS' REBUKE CAME AFTER AN
OBAMA APPOINTEE RULED AGAINST
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS TO
IMPOSE NEW RESTRICTIONS ON
ASYLUM CASES, A MOVE THE
PRESIDENT SEEM TO THINK WAS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED, PERHAPS
BECAUSE, LIKE RULINGS FROM OBAMA
APPOINTED JUDGES IN HAWAII AND
MICHIGAN, THE PRESIDENT'S LATEST
POLICY PLANS WERE AGAIN HALTED,
AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
FRUSTRATION IS ANYTHING NEW BUT
I DO THINK IT IS KIND OF
HEIGHTENED.
I DO THINK EVERY POLICY RULE AND
REGULATION OR LAW THAT COMES OUT
RIGHT NOW JUST IMMEDIATELY
CHALLENGED.
>> MR. TRUMP HAS BEEN CRITICAL
OF ROBERTS BEFORE BUT IT IS RARE
THAT THE CHIEF JUSTICE ON THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND WOULD
RETURN, I'LL, ALBEIT SUBTLY.
>> JUSTICE REALLY LET US DOWN.
WHAT HE DID WITH OBAMACARE WAS
DISGRACEFUL.
>> THERE WAS NOTHING SUBTLE
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S SUPPORT
FOR SAUDI ARABIA TODAY, CALLING
THE KINGDOM'S LOW OIL PRICES A
BIG TAX CUT FOR AMERICA AND THE
WORLD.
NO MENTION IN THE KINGDOM'S ROLE
IN THE MURDER OF
JAMAL KHASHOGGI, OR THE PRESSURE
TO INCREASE ACTION ON THE SAUDI
ARABIAN MONARCHY.
THIS HAS SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
WRITING, ONE THING I LEARNED
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS, WHEN YOU
LOOK THE OTHER WAY CONCERNING
PROBLEMS IN THE MIDDLE EAST, IT
RARELY WORKS OUT.
WHILE QUESTIONS CONTINUE TO
SWIRL ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED TO THE SAUDI
JOURNALIST, THE WHITE HOUSE
DEALT WITH A DIFFERENT SET OF
QUESTIONS OF ITS OWN, DELIVERING
A SET OF RESPONSES TO A SERIES
OF QUERIES FROM THE MUELLER
TEAM, INCLUDING WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT KNEW ABOUT DON JR.'S
TRUMP TOWER MEETING WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
NO CONFIRMATION YET FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THAT REPORT WHICH
ALSO SUGGESTED THAT THEY MUELLER
TEAM ASKED THE PRESIDENT WHO WAS
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP ABOUT
COMMENTS HE MADE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL ABOUT THE RUSSIANS LOOKING
INTO SECRETARY CLINTON'S MISSING